yes
all right you may have a seat sir
all right mr shellhorn are you ready
i'm sorry
yeah we're going to address that now
before he comes in yeah before the joy
comes in
mr horn before we bring the jury in it
did come to my attention that when the
last witness was testifying
yes
mr harden before we proceed with the
jury it's come to my attention that
before you testified when the last
witness miss gray was testifying you may
have overheard some of that testimony
from
the people um
filming the proceedings is that accurate
i could overhear some of it coming from
outside the doors
when i was sitting outside
outside these doors or where it was
being recorded
both but sitting right there i could
overhear some of it was not muffled but
some of what was coming up okay what
were you able to make and make out any
of the specifics of the no because i
could only hear bits and pieces fine and
you were seated at the um there were
tables outside in the hallway okay
that's where you were seated yes okay
any follow-up um
no thank you judge come on i see no
problem what
maybe we'll have to keep our voices down
then
or have the witnesses have your
detective
i was not i was looking at mr shellhorn
when i said that
i was looking at mr shellhorn and i said
a collective wii
um is there any other i know this room
where we normally put witnesses
um
is being
used
by the news crew there is a bench at
this end
i i think in the future any states
witnesses should be seated down there
and not not right outside the courtroom
uh the detective indicated to me he
understands that all right thank you
detective
thank you mr horton all right we'll
bring the jurors in
mr horn traditionally just staying here
normally on what this is called and
after but since we're continuing
might be seated everyone will continue
with mr horton's testimony
go ahead mr shellhorn
and that last objection was uh addressed
by the court at the break and the
objection was overruled so
go ahead mr sheldon mr hart and i
apologize if i already asked you these
questions before the break so i'll
ask it again uh
do you know who george morris is i do
who is george morris he was it is a very
famous american show jumper and coach of
the american team
and approximately well have you ever met
him yes do you know if michael barrason
knows it yes had you ever had any
discussions with the defendant michael
barissone about george morris and his
teaching philosophies and those sorts of
things
yes
are you aware whether the defendant and
mr morris uh were friendly with one
another they were
now i think i had asked you a question
about whether you were familiar with the
august 5th 2019
punishment that safe sport handed down
to mr morris
are you familiar with that yes and i'm
not going to ask you any specifics about
the
uh allegations or findings or anything
but are you aware of what the punishment
that he received was yes what was that a
lifetime ban
and is that information something that
uh was very well known or or not very
well known in the equestrian community
very well known do you recall if you and
the defendant mr barristone ever
discussed that when it happened on
august 5th or in the days leading after
we did
now i want to draw your attention to the
summer of 2019.
you were living and working here at the
new jersey farm during that summer yes
and you indicated that you had lived on
the second floor apartment
of the farmhouse for a number of years
before that summer correct yes
was there some different living
situation in the summer of
2019 yes where were you living in the
summer of 2018
i was staying in a
temporary situation at the stables
now were you personally aware of
anything that had happened at the
farmhouse
that affected parts of the farmhouse
yes what are you aware of
there was a
flooding at the house um the winter
prior
and did you have a chance to at some
point when you came back to new jersey
go into the farmhouse or see what some
of the damages were yes
what parts of the farmhouse were damaged
to your memory
the
ceiling on the first floor
and
most of the first floor was damaged
how was the state of the basement
fairly damaged
was it damaged to the extent where
the working students couldn't live there
that summer
yes
now
was that part of the reason why you
weren't living in the second floor
apartment that summer
yes
and who was living in that apartment
that summer
a pardon me which apartment uh who was
living in the second floor apartment
during the summer of 2019 uh lauren and
her boyfriend rob and in case i didn't
ask you at the beginning of the direct
examination
uh who is lauren
lauren kanreck and who's rob
robert goodwin
now who's this was it your decision to
move out of that apartment
no
how did you feel about moving out of
that apartment
objection relevance
what's the relevance of it
i think as we've talked about it goes to
the state of mind of individuals at the
barn and
whether or not that had any impact on
the defendant
i don't think i don't think mr um
horned state of mind is an issue in this
case so
i'll sustain the objection
with respect to uh lauren canareck
what was her what was your knowledge of
her involvement and presence at the farm
she was there to train
are you aware if she owned any horses
yes and do you recall how many horses
she had
to my recollection she started with
three
were those horses and when you reference
three
would that be to the best of your
recollection horses that were boarded at
the farm
when she started and then that number
increased
over her time there
did you have any
professional or working relationship
with her yes and what was that
there were certain uh times during her
time there that i would
help her with her horses
and you indicated earlier an individual
named rob rob goodwin
yes
who is rob goodwin with respect to
lauren canary her boyfriend fiance
did you have any sort of a professional
relationship with rob
only to the extent that he would um
assist her with the horses
do you remember approximately when they
first started working with michael
barissone or when they first came to one
of his farms
to the best of my memory it was the
spring of 2018
and during the course of time that
they were boarding horses and training
with michael barissone
what was the nature of your personal or
social relationship with either of them
it varied over time
meaning what just in general
meaning there were times where we were
quite social
in times where we had no social
interaction
did you have any
direct or specific knowledge of the
agreement that ms kanerak or mr goodwin
had with the defender
out of general
and what was your general objection
hearsay
i think he can testify based on his
observations judge
well if it's his personal observations
not not what he heard from someone else
no i'm trying to elicit that he didn't i
think he said he didn't have direct or
specific knowledge so i'm going to ask
him his observations right as long as
it's crouched in those terms
so you indicated that you knew that ms
canorex had
a number of horses sported at the farm
yes and also i think you indicated that
she was there to train yes would that
have been for
herself as a rider for her horses uh or
a combination of the two a combination
are you aware of whether or not uh ms
canorack was paying any money
to the defendant uh
with respect to those services
that question goes to your own personal
knowledge not what you may have heard
from someone else did you have any
personal knowledge of that is my
understanding that she was
and you indicated that
ms canarac and mr goodwin were living in
the farmhouse that summer of 2019
yes do you have any personal knowledge
of the circumstances of them coming to
live there
coming to live at the apartment or at
the farm
were you a party or were you part of any
conversations about what led to them
living at the
farm well hold on hold on
were you part of any negotiations
yourself with regard to
ms canorack and mr goodwin staying at
the farm
no that's the answer
and so any information you have about it
came from other sources other than your
personal knowledge and interactions all
right
all right move on mr shellhorn
in you indicated that your relationship
with them uh
fluctuated yeah
what was the the state of your working
or professional relationship with warren
canorack in august of 2019
could you repeat the question what was
the state of your working or
professional relationship with lauren
kanarak in this
august of 2019.
i would at that time i was not uh
helping with her with her horses or her
riding
and are you aware from living at the
property uh
how would you describe the state of
uh things at the property in august of
2019
extremely tense
now i think you indicated that the
working students
were not living at the farmhouse that
summer
correct and you may have already
answered this i apologize where were
they living
they were living in various locations
around the stables or the club room of
the of the farm
do you know
whether
michael barrasson and mary haskins gray
were living together during that summer
they were do you know where they were
living at least at the beginning of that
summer season
uh
also in the farmhouse at the
on the farm do you know what
living area they were living in
to the best of my recollection the main
floor
are you aware whether at some point they
moved out of that house
yes do you know where they went
they went also to the stables the barn
do you recall if anyone else was staying
at the barn
who
didn't live there on a more regular
basis at the beginning of august 2019
uh richard gray
who did you know that to be
the father of mary haskins gray
had ruth cox ever come back to the farm
yes and are you aware whether she was
there on an overnight basis at some
point during august 2019. she was
are you aware whether michael barrissone
ever met with a lawyer during august of
2019
yes were you present for any of those
meetings no
during the course of time that lauren
canareck and rob goodwin were at the
farm meaning either new jersey or
florida did you ever hear lauren
canorack make any direct threats of
violence to michael barrisson
no
did you ever hear mike robert goodwin
make any direct threats of violence to
michael barrison no
working with the defendant michael
barisson for the number of years that
you did
did you ever see or hear him lose his
temper
yes
and what would a typical reaction be if
he lost his temper
be very vocal
i want to draw your attention to
wednesday of august 7th do you recall
what you were doing that day
specifically in the early afternoon
i was
working horses
riding
do you recall where you were doing that
uh in the um
in the covered arena on the farm
do you recall if you spoke or interacted
with michael barristone at all that day
earlier in the day
do you recall
generally what his demeanor was
out of his mind
do you recall speaking to him at all or
interacting with him that
afternoon knew
did you see him yelling or otherwise
carrying on that day i did not did you
hear or see him running around the farm
or the clubhouse or the bar i did not
up until the events of the middle of the
afternoon on august 7th would you say
that that was more or less an ordinary
day at the farm
in terms of your day-to-day work for me
yes
now at some point on august 7th did you
become aware that police were at the
property
i did do you recall in general how you
became aware of that
i believe i saw lights
first over the hill
now do you have any personal knowledge
of what occurred at the farmhouse that
afternoon i do not
and do you still have any ongoing
business with michael verasam
i still operate a portion of my business
from his uh farm in florida
judge i don't have any further questions
for mr hardin thank you all right
cross-examination
mr hardened up
when lauren cataract and her
boyfriend robert goodwin
first came to the property
you were very friendly with them correct
correct
we've been socialized with them correct
correct
and can i assume that uh
that relationship changed at some point
yes
was laurent cataract causing problems at
barrisone dressage
yes
was she creating a toxic environment
based on your personal observations
yes um you indicated that you were
training her
when she first
joined
uh i i believe it wasn't when she first
joined okay we're at some point at some
point yes you started training her and
did she always show up to her lessons
no
did she come at
late hours to the
barn or stable area
after hours
she had
and did that create a problem to
all the people that were living in that
area
it did it
it did
and and were you aware of
the social media posts
being posted by lauren cataract i was
and
how did those social media posts affect
michael barriston
uh judge i'm going to object to the
formula question
yeah i wanted to rephrase it
you were aware that lauren conoract was
posting things on
social media correct correct did you
ever talk to michael barrasson about
those not specifically did you have a
discussion regarding that just answer
yes or no yes
and
what effect did you observe
with respect
to michael barisson
with respect to those
um they made him extremely paranoid and
fearful for the
um the farm and everything on it
now
you indicated on direct that he was
living in the farmhouse
underneath cataract and goodwin
yes
at some point of time he moved out of
there
and started living not in this house but
in the
club area in the stables correct yes did
you have a discussion with him regarding
that move
yes
and can you tell me what effect
you observed with respect to michael
barrasson
after that incident
um
he was too fearful to be in his own home
that's based on your observations yes
he physically showed
what you recognized as fear correct yes
now this woman cox that the prosecutor
referred to
um did you have discussions with her
with regards to what was going on
yes
did you observe fear
objection
what's the basis for the objection the
ongoing objection judge the state of
mind of other individuals is not
relevant i think you've made that ruling
a number of times
what's the relevance of cox's state of
mind isn't the issue mr barris home
shows the overall
toxic environment that affected
everyone and if it affects cox obviously
it would affect mr barriston more
because he's dealing with that
let's not get into that mr bolenkis
it's not a that's not a proper comment
i'll i'll allow the question
and answer
did you observe fear in mrs cox
yes
was she sleeping in these stables
in front of her horse because of that
hold on a second now that's going a
little too far mr blinkist
you're asking him to opine on why she
was doing something that's not within
his province
if he saw her sleep in there he can say
i saw her sleeping there and when that
happened but not the reasons that's
something internal to her
did you see
miss cox sleeping
in her stalls
in front of her horse
yes
i didn't ask you what
the content was but did you have a
discussion with her with regards to that
just answer yes or no did you have a
discussion with miss cox all right he
did next question
now
that's safe in the office
um you indicated that you occasionally
had access to it yes
um
was the safe effort left open
no to your knowledge not to my knowledge
no
did you ever see mary haskins go into
that safe
yes
um
do you know how she got the combination
to that safe
no
now the prosecutor showed you pictures
of the
stable area where the horses are
housed
is there a rubber floor
in that
area yes and what's the purpose of that
um so the horses don't slip on the
concrete
now
you indicated that it was your
understanding that
strikeout
to your knowledge was lauren tatarak
paying
for her living accommodations
hold on
what wasn't that objected to when
i asked that question and it was
objective
can you allow them to answer and i
believe
generally speaking yes
not
move
details
was lauren cataract the only
client on the property
that was living there full time
yes
did you find that unusual
it was not normal
now
you indicated that in august of 2019
that
it was extremely
tense
at barriston dressage correct yes
and was intense because of cataract and
goodwin
yes
you indicated that mary gray's father
came up
do you know why he came up
from personal knowledge
not from what other people told you
she wanted him there to feel so she felt
safer
you were at the uh staples the morning
of the seventh correct
yes
was there a incident between robert
goodwin and the blacksmith or furrier on
that morning yes
and we're not going to ask you what
were any statements
made
that you're aware of by robert goodwin
yes
now
you indicated that when michael barrison
loses his temper
he becomes vocal
yes raises his voice correct yes maybe
yells a little bit correct
yes
have you ever seen him get physical
absolutely not
now
leading up to the days of the shooting
did you see a
significant mental decline in michael
barrasso objection
he can't testify about that mr
belinkus he's not an expert witness
can you describe your observations
of michael barrasso
say for the last two or three days
prior to the shooting
i would say he was in an almost
catatonic state
hadn't been sleeping eating
glazed overlook in his eyes just zombies
anything
no
shaving no
was he walking the property at night
to your knowledge
yes did you see that yourself in other
words not what you heard you saw it
yourself yes all right very good
was he desponding
explain sorry
despondent
uh depressed
extremely
was he able
to perform
the everyday functions
normally associated with running his
business
no the first time in 18 years i had seen
him that way
did he cancel clinics yes
did he show up to to ride when he uh
normally did no
did he withdraw
absolutely
were you concerned about him based on
your observations
hundred percent
i have nothing further on any redirect
just briefly your honor uh mr hardin
from having known
mr barrissone for the length of time
that you did
uh would it be fair to say that he
did have other emotional or mental
struggles during the time you knew him
with for example anxiety
yes and that existed before he met miss
canaric
yes he also had issues with depression
yes and that existed before he met her
yes
nothing further judge all right
one more question
based on based on that yes absolutely
the observations of depression and
anxiety that you observed
on prior occasions
were these
observations
leading up to the day of the shooting
much much worse
extremely worse
all right you may step down thank you
did man look out in the hall and just
make sure the next witness is here sure
go to the state we'll next call ruth cox
watch your stuff please
uh please remain standing for a moment
if you could place your left hand on the
bible please raise your right hand my
court clerk will administer an oath to
you do you swim in the presence of
almighty god that the testimony you give
to this court regarding this matter
shall be the truth the whole truth and
nothing but the truth yes ma'am please
state your name and spell your last name
for the record
ruth pence cox my last name is c-o-x
thank you all right miss cox you wanna
have a seat thank you
please keep your voice up nice and loud
so we have jurors in the jury box and
also in the first two rows in the
gallery
that microphone um
just records doesn't amplify your voice
okay so keep your voice up but if i'm
not speaking loud enough please let me
know all right jurors you don't hear
anything please just raise your hand and
we'll have the witness raise her voice a
little bit
and if you don't understand the question
miss cox posed by one of the attorneys
or the court if i happen to ask a
question just indicate you don't
understand that's fine i don't want you
answering a question if you don't
understand it okay all right very good
go ahead mr shellhorn
could you please introduce yourself to
the jury and tell them where you live
yes you want me to give my name again
if you would okay dr ruth cox and i live
in new bern north carolina
and dr cox do you know michael barrison
yes sir i do you see him in court today
yes sir would you identify him by an
article of clothing he's wearing
a dark-colored tie
she's identified by climbing all right
for the record uh miss cox has
identified the defendant mr barroson
dr cox do you also know an individual or
no of an individual named warren cameron
i do and do you know her through your
association with michael barrasson i do
approximately how many times would you
say that you've ever interacted with it
maybe three times
do you know an individual named robert
goodwin yes and do you know her of him
through your association with michael
bearson yes
i want to direct your attention back to
august of 2019 were you in new jersey at
the beginning of the month of august
2019. i was
specifically do you recall where you
were
you mean at his stables is that the
question you're asking where where were
you staying i was staying at his stables
yes sir meaning the defendant michael
barry yes michael versus unstable yes
sir do you recall where that stable is
located in long valley
and on august 4th through august 5th
were you having a conversation with the
defendant in the stables on that
property yes sir i was did he ask you
for something yes sir what did he ask
you for
uh he wanted to see a gun that i had in
my car
do you recall what kind of gun that was
it is a nine millimeter ruger it's a
small pistol
and is there do you recall what color or
coloring it was
uh yes sir the bottom part of it is a
pinkish in color like pink camo
if camo do you know what i mean yes sir
yes
short for camouflage camo yes yes yes
sir camouflage yes go ahead mr shawn
thank you doctor uh did uh he take that
handgun from you during the course of
that conversation yes sir he did
and on august 7th of 2019 are you aware
that an incident occurred at the
farmhouse on that property
yes sir i am do you have any personal
knowledge of that
of what happened outside the farmhouse
i was not present to it i know that
there was a shooting
did you come to find that out after the
fact yes after the fact yes sir meaning
you didn't witness what actually
happened absolutely not
now at some point on august 7th were you
still at the stable in the clubhouse
when the police came yes sir i was and
did you have a
conversation with them or were you
interviewed by the police on that day
yes sir i was that after that afternoon
and that evening and did you come to
find out at some point after the
shooting that that handgun that you gave
to the defendant had been recovered by
the police on the property unfortunately
sir i did
dr cox i want to ask you some questions
uh about that weapon uh were you charged
with a crime related to that firearm yes
sir i was
do you recall what the specific charge
was that you were charged with
i don't know the legal terms that you
would use but i'm sure that you could
tell me but it had to do with bringing a
weapon into your state
and did it also have to do with
unlawfully transferring it to another
person yes sir it did
now do you recall appearing before judge
taylor on december 13 2021 on a zoom or
a virtual hearing yes sir i did and you
recall
let me rephrase that question were you
represented by an attorney yes sir i was
do you recall what the purpose of that
hearing on december 13th was yes the
purpose was to put on be put on a
program
a pre-trial intervention program
and what is your understanding of what
uh pre-trial intervention is
uh it's a
you know i'm not going to use legal
terms because i don't know all the legal
terms but it is a type of probation in
which i will
respond to a probation officer which i
have come to make contact with
and i will follow all the rules and
regulations that i'm asked to do
according to all the documents that i
signed related to that
now do you recall what the maximum
punishment you could have gotten if you
didn't enter into pti was for that crime
uh i think according to your laws i
could have gotten 18 months in
uh jail
and what was the
period of supervision
or or probationary supervision that you
were given as part of the pti 36 months
have you been compliant with the
supervision at this point absolutely sir
i have
did you go over the pti order that was
signed by you
and me and judge taylor
yes sir and that was also signed by your
lawyer yes sir
and did that also require you to forfeit
or surrender the firearm that we were
just discussing yes sir
have you met with me and other members
of my office at times over
zoom or teams or something like that yes
sir
and at times was your attorney present
for some of those meetings yes sir
now i want to draw your attention back
to
michael barisson can you tell the jury
approximately when it is that you first
met him
i met him about five years before the
incident happened
down in
new bern north carolina
and you recall what the circumstances of
that meeting were in new bern yes sir
i owned a horse with mary haskins gray
and we were looking for someone to help
us with this horse because we thought he
had great potential
mary haskins had known michael and
thought that he would be helpful to us
and she had asked him to come down there
to a horse clinic where there would be
multiple lessons that he would give and
as you know he's an olympian and a very
good horseman and people would be
interested to come and take lessons from
him and that's how i first met him
over time
did you get to know him
better yes sir i did and did you also
enter into a co-ownership agreement of a
horse with him yes sir i did what was
the horse that you owned together with
the defendant uh it was a fall named
lady guardian
and i'm sure everybody buys horses for
different reasons what's the reason that
you
would buy a horse or invest in a horse
uh we thought this horse would have a
potential for dressage and um mary
haskins would be the person who would be
his rider
and did you have any feelings about
michael barrasson being the trainer of
that horse
i had positive feelings about that yes
sir
over the course of time uh that you knew
the defendant and you entered into some
of these business arrangements with him
did your
relationship with them move beyond just
business and become more of a friendship
yes sir
now i think you indicated that you owned
a horse or horses with
mary haskins gray yes sir do you recall
how many horses you owned with her two
what were the names of those horses don
divone was one horse and jolina was the
second horse
did you own any other horses besides
tonda bone jolina or lady garden no sir
where were those horses boarded they
were boarded at michael bears on stables
did you pay mr barrisone with respect to
the boarding yes sir i did did you pay
him as well for training the horses yes
sir
now i think you indicated already that
you are familiar with the
long valley farm
yes sir are you familiar with whether or
not michael barrason owns another stable
or farm elsewhere yes sir where is that
loxahatchee florida and did you have an
opportunity during the course of your
relationship with uh michael barissone
to visit both of those farms at times
yes sir
is it fair to say
those visits went from being strictly
business to being business and personal
or social yes
did you ever stay overnight in new
jersey when you came to visit yes sir
where would you typically stay if if
there was a typical place
well i would i would stay somewhere on
the farm there were different
opportunities for places for me to spend
the night so i would usually stay on the
farm at some place it would change from
time to time time to time
can you generally describe for the jury
they've already seen some diagrams of
the property but what's your
recollection of the general layout or
some of the features of the property
uh it's a lovely piece of property
from the road there's a hill that goes
up
to to the top obviously of the hill
there's a historic house that's there
that's several stories high which he
restored up at the top on the other side
of the hill there's a large horse
complex
that includes a club room
and behind that club room there's a
lovely indoor arena
to the left of that club room there is a
garage in which michael had his cars he
loved antiques cars to the right there
was a long stables that came to the
right behind all of that there was
another small stables over there
and you went down the hill on the other
side and below that was where the young
stock was kept and there was a small
stable down there that was used for
feeding them and giving them hay
and there were several outdoor
paddocks and there was also an outdoor
dressage arena over to the
right now you indicated that if you're
driving on the
driveway that you would come up to a
rise or a hill
uh if you went over the hill to where
the
stables and the clubhouse and that sort
of thing are could you see to the
farmhouse
you could see the upper part of the of
the farmhouse yes i mean it was like
three stories high so you could see the
upper part of the farmhouse yes sir
now you described a little bit about the
uh
the layout of the stable and the club
room
what are some of your distinctive
memories of the club room area
um
the club room had a very long table uh
in the middle of it it had furniture
that you could sit and look out from the
from the club room into the dressage
arena which was a very nice thing
particularly when it got chillier there
was a kitchen
uh very often there were parties in
there like just an example july the 4th
we usually had a cookout there was a
a porch on the front as you walked into
the club room so there were various
social activities that would happen in
that club room
what kind of things do you remember
would be hanging on the walls in that
club room
there was memorability that michael had
from his various uh
years uh
in his horse his horse world uh there
were various championship ribbons that
he had
uh there were letters from people that
he had helped in the horse world
thanking him
for helping him on the walls
now when you weren't at the property or
weren't at one of the farms how
frequently would you communicate with
the defendant
i did not commute i was just trying to
think on how to answer that i did not
communicate with him very often
more because mary haskins was
later
living up there i would more communicate
with her
now what was your experience or let me
ask you some questions about your
experience related to
the the business that michael varizone
was running
uh do you know how many different stalls
there were at the new jersey farm for
horses for example
i never counted
um
okay i'm going to say 20 plus
and what was your experience with uh
with with the number of horses that may
be in those stalls
i'm not sure what you're asking me in
other words uh were the stalls typically
more full more empty or something in the
middle oh absolutely more full
uh he had some of his horses and he had
a lot of horses like mine who he had
clients uh for
so it was mainly full
are you aware whether he had any
employees or people working for him yes
sir what was your understanding
uh he had he had a gentleman who mucked
out the stalls in the morning
and he he usually had one or two working
students
what did you know the working students
to do based on your observations or what
you saw
they would groom the horses they would
get the horses tacked up and saddled to
be ridden and there was a constant
exchange of horses between
when michael was there between michael
between mary haskins and between justin
and so the working students took care of
that they also took care of the feeding
now you introduce yourself as a doctor
yes sir can you tell the jury a little
bit about your own professional
experience and what you do for a living
okay do you want me to talk about the
degrees that i hold is that what you're
asking me to do what's what's your edu
what's your background in education okay
all right so
i hold a diploma degree in nursing which
is a three-year degree i have a bachelor
of science in nursing i have a master's
of science in psych mental health
nursing
i have a phd degree in marriage and
family therapy
and i am a family nurse practitioner and
a psych mental health practitioner
and in a nutshell what do you do
now
uh what is your occupation now what's
your practice entail okay so uh in the
town that i live in i work for several
different agencies there
uh
doing medication management and also
doing individual and family therapy
were you ever engaged in a formal
professional relationship based on your
position with michael barrisson no sir i
was not
did you ever interact with him in that
regard on a personal or a friendly level
please ask that question in a different
way
did you ever uh interact with him or
have any dealings with him
on a on a personal level that drew on
your professional background yes
based on the period of time that you
knew the defendant did you ever observe
anything when you were with him
related to his running the business
yes sir what might that be
um
i observed how he managed his time how
he managed his clinics
his buying of selling of hay
his
interest in different types of feed
those type things
did you ever have any observations or
even talk to him with regard to any
concerns he had about his finances or
about the financial aspects of running a
business
we discussed that at times because he
was always very cognizant of uh being
able to fund this large organization
which is he alone was funding so
uh yes we discussed that at times
that sort of leads in into my next
question uh set of questions which is
about uh how expensive it can be to own
a horse
how much do you want to spend
well what uh what are some factors that
could affect how much a horse costs to
buy
well the factors would be their breeding
would be how you want to use this horse
if you just want a horse that you can
trail ride then you're not looking at a
real expensive horse the kinds of horses
that were there at those stables the
kind of horses that myself and mh were
interested in were much much higher
priced horses that we were looking
forward to doing
the top level dressage national and
international competition
and what are some of the ongoing
expenses that you may have after you
buy the horse oh buying the horse was
just the simple thing
so then you have
feed you have hay
you have watering you have ferrier bills
you have debt bills you have tach
you have boarding if you're going to
boarding somewhere you have training you
need a trailer you need a truck
does that help you
is that just the tip of the iceberg yeah
that's why i'm smiling yes
now you indicated that your purpose in
wanting to buy those horses and your
aspirations with the horses was to get
them to the highest levels if possible
absolutely
what role or effect does a trainer have
in trying to accomplish a goal like that
oh the trainer uh is has a lot of
responsibility in terms of their
understanding of what it takes to do
that both for the horse and for the
rider and the experience that they had
had
to be able to do that
and based on your experience in the
equestrian industry
similar to how you said if you have
aspirations for a horse it may cost more
does it cost more for a better trainer
oh absolutely yes sir
where would you or how would you
evaluate the defendant as a trainer
based on your observations exceptional
now i want to direct your attention and
ask you some questions uh about the gun
um you mentioned earlier about owning a
gun
and can you remind the jury what kind of
a gun that was
it was a nine millimeter ruger very
small handgun
do you remember when you bought that gun
approximately
sometimes
in the beginning of 2016.
and you recall where you purchased it
what state
no sir i do not
where were you living at the time i was
living in north carolina
and can you describe for the jury what
were some of the steps that you had to
take in order to be able to purchase the
gun
yes sir the gun that i was looking for
was very difficult to find because it
was a small gun so i went on the
internet
and called and contacted various uh
dealers pawn shops and it ended up that
this gun came from i can tell you
somewhere in the midwest it was sent
from there to a pawn shop in newberry
now did you
just find the gun order it online and
then walk into the pawn shop in newborn
new bern and pick it up
uh i did go in
i did go in and pick it up but i had to
sign for it
did you have to do any other paperwork
or go through any sort of checks or
anything like that an application
process in order to buy the gun
yes sir i did in north carolina
you can have a concealed carry permit
and for in north carolina for that you
have to go to a class
for that
then you have to go through the
sheriff's department to apply
for the concealed carry permit
i had to be fingerprinted
i had to fill out various forms right
now i don't remember how many but it
just wasn't one or two and then you had
to have background check checks done
both in the criminal
system and in the mental health system
and after all that comes back is that
when you get some sort of a permit and
you're allowed to go pick up the gun yes
sir
now you indicated that you wanted to
purchase this particular gun uh what was
the reason you wanted to buy this
specific gun i have a very small hand
very small finger so i needed a gun that
had a very small grip
what was the reason that you bought the
gun
uh i was going to do park target
shooting i have some friends that have
guns and so
we were interested in doing that
together
did you ever uh travel with the gun
at times i did yes and uh specifically
did you ever travel with the gun when
you would come up from new bern to the
huang valley farm i did at times uh due
to safety issues because i would leave
newborn after work in the afternoon and
there is no straight way to drive from
newburn to long valley so you have to in
three or four o'clock in the morning i'm
driving through the countryside in the
dark
and uh so at times when that would be
happening yes i would have that with me
what's the approximate amount of time it
would take you to drive from newburn to
long valley
between 11 and 12 hours
did you ever take the gun with you when
you would go down to the farm in
loxahatchee no sir i did not
can you tell the jury when you would
travel with the gun how would you
transport it
uh
so the gun itself was transported um
with a
in the clip with a plastic clip
in the magazine that came with the gun
so the gun was not loaded the gun was in
a pouch by itself
i had a truck at that time
and so uh we were taught in a in our uh
course that the best place to put the
gun is in the trunk of your car and
since i do not have a truck uh in the
car it was in the back seat on the
passenger side against the door in the
back seat which would be
the farthest away you know for me to if
i wanted to try and get it i could not
reach it
now you indicated that you would keep
that orange uh
plastic magazine inside the gun yes sir
did the gun come with any other uh
magazines to put bullets into
yes sir it came with one
how many did you typically have with the
gun two
did the gun have any sort of a case or
anything else
you mean when it when i bought it when
you bought it no it did not come in a
cage did you buy a case for it yes sir i
did what kind of case did you buy it was
a
material plastic case that had a zipper
and the inside was had like velvet
material you know crush material for the
gun and a pocket for the gun on the
outside there was a zipper for the
magazines
now
judge if i could approach
certainly
judge for the record i'm going to
hand forward s177 i believe that's
already in evidence it is s 181 already
in evidence
s 202 in evidence and s 178 which is not
yet in evidence but i would like to
offer it at this time
178.
so
it's 179 that hasn't been admitted yet
178 is admitted in evidence the other
items are already in evidence
dr cox if we could start with the uh
white box there
that should have a red sticker on it
that says
s177
yes sir
can you open that up
please
and from looking at that what is it
it's a ruger
pistol
and is that the same uh ruger pistol
that you
uh purchased back sometime in 2016
if it's the same serial number yes sir
it is can you see the serial number
there
yes i can
is that the same serial number or do you
want to look at something to refresh
your memory
i don't i don't have that number in my
mind
but i know but i know that you all
checked it out
well just for purposes of the record i'm
going to show you uh
i think it's s170
which i'll stipulate that sort of gun
why
parties are stipulating that uh the
serial mat the serial number on that gun
matches the record so it is in fact your
gun the parties have stipulated to that
all right
yes yes sir it is my girl
mr shellhorn did you catch the witness's
answer she did acknowledge that that was
in fact her gun thank you all right very
good move on next question
dr cox if you could just hold that gun
up and show it to the jury
and if it helps you to stand up you
could do that too
you want me to walk
around they've already seen it
yeah just sold it off
i'm sure they appreciate your offer
now dr cox win and you can put it down
thank you
when you uh had that gun on august uh in
the beginning of august of 2019 and the
defendant took it from you
did it have all those various safety
mechanisms on it no sir it did not
did i apologize i forgot to hand up
s-191
so i'm going to hand that out and ask if
that could be identified at this time
it should be moved into evidence at this
time
i think it's already in evidence
s 191
yes it is it is it is it's in evidence
dr cox i'm going to ask you what s 191
if you could open that
and
take out what's in that bag
what is that
it is a gun case and that's the gun case
you indicated earlier it didn't come
with the gun but you bought it on your
own
now
would it be typical for you to travel
from north carolina to new jersey
if you had the gun with you to have it
in that case yes sir
would you have that case inside anything
else when you travel i have a i have a
backpack
that uh
i would have it in
that contains
uh for instance uh the gun cleaning
equipment and then earphones uh that are
to be used when you
do target you
uh was there anything else in there did
you ever carry ammunition yes there'd be
ammunition in there as well yes
now
have you
having having owned that gun
uh for a number of years have you
actually shot that gun yes sir i have
can you describe for the jury
when you would get to for example a
shooting range what would be the steps
that you would take to prepare that gun
to shoot
so uh there would be a table out at the
range
and so uh we have objects for relevance
what's the relevance mr um shellhorn
such state of mind is an issue this case
and
certainly this is the gun that the state
is alleging was used in the shooting i
think the process that would go into
shooting the gun by someone who has
actual knowledge of shooting the gun is
relevant all right i'll allow it overall
i should answer yes go ahead you can
answer man okay and dr cox don't ask me
ask the judge yes
yes no it's all right no worries yes i
won't do that again it's okay go ahead
you can answer the question yes you can
there would be a table there and there
were
multiple people there shooting and there
would be a range officer and the officer
would give us certain commands about
what to do with the gun reminding us all
ways to put the gun going downrange and
they would tell us when we could put the
clip in
and when the range was hot and when the
range was cold
backing up just a little bit then when
you would get there uh to the range and
you were going to shoot the gun uh when
you arrived there would it have that
orange plastic magazine still in the gun
yes sir yes sir it would
and so you would have to remove that yes
sir what's the process that goes into
removing that orange
plastic clip from the gun well on the
side of the gun there's a little button
that lets the clip come out so you'd
have to push that button to get the clip
to come out judge if i could just
approach and
sure go ahead
i'm sure he can't hold this up at the
same time but i'm going to ask if you
can point out
do you see
where that would be it's over it's over
on the other side it's on the other side
and
can you point out to the jury the
general area on the other side where
that would be so it'd be on this side on
the other side so you could take your
thumb and you can push that and it would
drop the clip out and do you have s202
in front of you there i think it's this
right here
can you just open that up
is that your look like your orange clip
absolutely so where would that go or
where would that fall out of so that
would fall out here
and the purpose of that is what safety
so you would have to take that out of
the gun before you could load bullets oh
absolutely yes sir
when you would typically get to the
range dr cox would you have bullets
loaded into the magazine or would you
have to do that when you got to the
range tissue um i usually carried one or
two magazines in this case wearing the
zipper thing
so
i may have one magazine that was loaded
and the other magazine i would have to
load
and i'll just ask you if you could uh
look at s 177 which is one of those
folders in front of you or envelopes in
front of you
i got a 178 and a 181 i'm sorry
178.
does that appear to be one of the
magazines for your gun yes sir
and are there bullets in that right now
yes sir there are
do you recall if there were bullets in
that magazine when you gave it to
michael barrison
there would have been one of the
magazines there were two magazines one
of them would would surely have had uh
the bullets in it the other one may not
have had
you can put that back in the uh
now you indicated it maybe
you would typically have ammunition not
in that case that's in front of you
that's s 191 but in your backpack in
your car yes sir
do you recall what kind of ammunition
you would typically buy
it would be nine millimeter
and would you buy a particular brand or
something else no sir
because all i was doing was target
shooting i bought the cheapest bullets
that were out there in in north carolina
you can buy bullets at various different
places so
if i came across some i would buy them
judge if i can approach again sure
dr cox i'm going to show you what's been
marked as s 190
and i'll
leave that if you could just take that
out
do you recognize
s-190
i know what it is
yes sir
it's a is a box of bullets do you know
if that box of bullets was was yours or
not
no sir i do not know did you give any
bullets or ammunition to michael
barissone in a box or that sort of thing
absolutely sir i did not
all right you can put that back in the
envelope thank you
doctor i'm going to ask you some
questions about august of 2019
almost when of 2019
19 2009
[Music]
i think you indicated that you knew of
lauren canareck and rob goodwin through
your association with michael barrison
yes sir
did you have any
did you have any personal knowledge of
whatever agreements or arrangements they
had with michael barrison yes sir what
was your personal knowledge
the
small bit of knowledge that i had was
that
michael had an arrangement with lauren
and her family that
i'm judge it's got to be here
where did you acquire your knowledge
from dr cox where did i yeah did you
hear it from michael bearson
what
um
it's not hearsay
it comes from the defendant well it's
hearsay but there's a um
exception that they hear say well
803b
would let it in
one in particular go ahead i'm sorry to
cut you off go ahead ask a question
again mr sheldhorn
dr cox did you have conversations with
michael barassone about the nature of
the business relationship he had with
lauren canorack or robert goodwin or
their family yes sir what was your
understanding from the defendant of that
relationship lauren had several horses
there that she was working with uh with
michael bearson
and my understanding was that they
exchanged part of that board cost
for rob to do some work
at michael's property
and did you observe around the property
what some of that work was yes sir i did
and in general terms what what did that
consist of it is consisted of in the
stable some new wiring new lights and uh
putting in a ceiling in that stable
and uh in the home down near the street
working on the cellar that was there to
produce some new bedrooms and some new
plumbing there
do you remember when you came back
to new jersey in august of 2019 what day
it would either have been a thursday or
a friday
if i uh told you it was approximately
august 2nd
was that sound
i think it was friday
it is a little bit leading mr she's
trying to refresh your memory judge
well do you have something
other than your own memory you can
refresh your memory with it i ask the
court to take
judicial notice of uh
what's the date
i'm just double checking so i make the
record clear your honor
that that august
august 2nd was a friday judge according
to the calendar on my computer yes i
will take i have a
computer as well
um i see a calendar
and it is um
august 2nd was a friday
does that sound generally consistent
with your recollection yes sir that
would be
when you arrived back to the property on
that date what was your observation
about the state of people and things
going on at the property
uh it was a very tense uh situation
um people were worried
unsure about what
was going to be happening
people were hesitant about
kind of going some goings and comings
but generally everybody was upset
when you got back to the property did
you know all of the specific details of
what had been going on or was that just
basically your general impression when
you got here
i didn't know all the details but i i
understood that there was conflict
between michael bearson
and
lauren canary
now over the next several days from the
time you got there
uh
would you say that things
got better got worse or stayed the same
oh no sir they got much much worse day
after day after day
were you ever present at uh the property
when michael barrasson's lawyer came
yes sir
and do you recall if you were a party to
or a part of any conversation or meeting
you would have had with the lawyer yes
sir
and without getting into the specifics
of what anyone said during that meeting
what was your general impression of
the purpose for the meeting jackson joke
it has to be based on this yeah it is
based on hearsay
where did the meeting take place miss
cox uh it took place in the club room at
the stables were you present yes sir
who else was present
uh michael was there i believe mary
haskins was there the lawyer was there
and
it could have been that mary haskins
father was there
because he had come up to the staples
right
approximately how long was the
conversation
uh the conversation was probably half an
hour 45 minutes
all right thank you
during the uh mr shellhorn i think i i
think
i'm going to sustain them
any further questioning about it would
elicit hearsay statements of others so
it's a classic hearsay and therefore not
admissible judge can i get an uh
conversation
do you recall the date dr cox oh
absolutely not sir
go ahead mr shellhorn
doctor i want to ask you some specific
questions about that conversation that
you had with uh with michael barissone
about the gun
do you recall where on the property that
conversation happened i do where was
that
uh it was in the uh long aisle
of all those stables up near
the wash stalls outside of don devone's
stable
judge i would like to show a photo it's
s319
i don't believe that that has been
identified or moved into evidence at
this time
i apologize it has i think it was with
the last witness
yes 319 isn't evidence
doctor i think that may be on your
screen in front of you as well too if
that's easier for you that is easier yes
sir um
what is s319 a picture
of this is a picture of the long aisle
on the right hand side of the stables
where the
majority of the stables were and what's
at the far end of the aisle there
so at the far end there are two wash
stalls on the right
and where you see that kind of black
hole it goes out into a docking bay
and at that end of the
at that end of the aisle
if you were to take a left into that
hallway where does that go
so when you got to the end of this aisle
if you went left yes you went into the
indoor arena
and the clubhouse was right in front of
that and the clubhouse was in front of
that
where was the the stall where don devone
your horse was uh was boarded
his would have been so if you're walking
down this hallway
this would have been the last stall
before you get to the wash dolls
no is that the area that you were in
when you had that conversation with the
defendant yes sir
did he
come and approach you or or did you go
and approach him
he came and approached me
and do you remember approximately
what day that was
it would have been on either like friday
or saturday it was late in the evening
when that happened
do you recall
generally what the defendant asked you
or said to you
yes
the conversation started out just
generally about what was going on and
then he asked me if i had brought my gun
with me on this trip and i said i had he
wanted to see it had he ever asked you
to see your gun before he had not asked
me to see it we had talked about it but
he had not asked to actually see it
before
uh what did you do after he asked you
that
uh he wanted to see it so i got the gun
from my car in the case that you saw
here
and we looked at it and where did you
look at it with the defendant in front
of don duval stall
was anyone else in the area at that time
no sir there were not
you said that that was at nighttime it
was late in the evening
can you
give an approximate time when you say
late in the evening what does that mean
around midnight or
after he know where the handgun was or
did he just ask you to go get it
well how would he know that
that's what i'm asking do you mean if he
said anything about it like go get it
from the car or word sonata did he yes
i'll rephrase the question judge
please do that did he ask you
specifically to go get it out of the car
yes
when you brought it back in you had said
that it was still in that case yes sir
and were the
two magazines in the case with it yes
the orange plastic clip was in the uh
handgun itself yes sir and i think you
said that uh
possibly one of the clips was fully
loaded yes do you recall how much
ammunition or how many bullets
one of those
magazines held seven
but your recollection is that one of
them would have been empty
it could have been empty or it could
have just had one or two bullets in it
did he give you the handgun back after
he looked at it no sir he did not did he
open
the case and look at the handgun itself
or did he just look at the case
we just we looked at the case and opened
it up to see the handgun and then closed
it back up
do you remember if he took the handgun
out of the case at all no
no he did not take it out of the case
did you see
where he took it specifically yes sir he
took it into
uh the club room
did you watch where he went from there
no sir i did not
did he tell you what he was going to do
with it no sir he did not did you ask
him what he was going to do no sir i did
not did you have any concerns with
giving it to him at that time absolutely
sir i did not at that time
now i'll draw your attention uh to
august 7th which is a wednesday
do you remember what you were doing let
me ask this were you still at the farm
on wednesday august 7. yes sir i was and
you recall what you were doing that
morning yes sir um i was at that long
table that we had talked about before i
was sitting at the end of the long table
that was next to the front windows doing
some work on my computer
my laptop
mr shellhorn yes
do you know how much longer you're going
to be approximately
uh
10 to 15 minutes so i could either
finish now or i could
well it's 4 35 now
i think either way we'll probably need
tomorrow anyway so we've got to do
crosstalk all right but i don't
anticipate taking a long time to finish
with myself i don't i don't want to go
too much over it was just five minutes
or so i'd say we could finish but
um
no i understand all right ladies and
gentlemen i i think we'll take our um
evening recess now it's a little bit
past 4 30
and um
there may be days when we stay a little
bit later to finish up but
it's too early in the trial to push it
so um
we'll break now we'll come back tomorrow
please be here around 8 30 or so so we
can get started as close to nine as
possible right please don't discuss the
case have a good evening everyone we'll
see you tomorrow thank you
sure you you can step down um dr cox
we'll see you tomorrow morning okay
thank you all right so i'm sure mr
sheldon may want to speak to you but
we'll figure we'll get started close to
nine o'clock so
maybe 8 30. i'll see you then i see you
again
officer officer officer just have her
stay down here until the jurors leave if
you would
it's dr cox yeah
mr shellhorn who's uh what's the batting
order for tomorrow
anticipate we would finish with dr uh dr
cox yes um i have vanessa medrano cortez
the dcpmp worker is slated to be here in
the morning and i anticipate ms canara
will be called tomorrow okay all right
very good thank you
so
oh judge
the defendant just reminded me i didn't
want to uh
give
mr harden and ms gray
the okay to be released
uh
i think they're finished at this point
so i was going to tell them they're free
to
travel back to florida and if there's a
need to recall them by the defense i
assume they'll make those arrangements
all right yeah i think that's the best
way to proceed especially since we're in
the middle of dr cox's testimony and
we're going to hear from ms canorack do
we have an estimate
judge based on where we are right now
somewhat dependent on cross-examination
obviously of course
i can make the representation of the
court that the doctor from the hospital
has
office days on mondays and thursdays so
he had asked so he didn't have to
postpone any surgeries
or operations which would be on tuesdays
wednesdays or fridays if he could be
called on one of those two days on
what days
if he could be called on a monday or a
thursday so i have him on standby have
him here for thursday assuming that
and where does he work at morristown
memorial
and so i i guess my point point being if
we don't get to him on thursday my
anticipation will be i would at least
need to call him on monday
all right well we'll probably get to him
um
we'll try to fit him in on thursday
if we have to take him a little bit out
of order we'll take him a little bit out
of order just to get it finished
should i tell him uh
i'll coordinate that just coordinate
tell them tell them thursday and
we'll see where we stand tomorrow at
close of business to see who's on the
stand and how much longer we anticipate
things going yes
so other than the doctrine but i don't
anticipate beyond that i think i only
have
three other witnesses
or or
all right so counselors are telling me i
have grossly uh at five
right but i don't think that there are
so
probably won't finish this week but
maybe early next week you'll find that
we'll be very close to finishing this
week yeah well again it depends on the
cross-examination
um of the witnesses but either at the
end of this week or early next week
all right but we'll try to get the
doctor in on um
on thursday
can i collect this evidence yes go ahead
let mr grosso have all the jurors left
all right very good
people observing the trial can now leave
we'll see you tomorrow
you